Hi, I'm Alex Les, VP of data science and
AI at Huge design and technology
company. And today I'm going to talk
about invisible users, invisible
interfaces, which is how teams can use
AI simulation to accelerate
design. We're going to talk about three
things today when it comes to the state
of UX and AI. One, where we are now.
Two, where we could be. and three, an
idea for how to get
there. So, in terms of where we are
today, unfortunately, the reality is
that AI has a trust gap. Some recent
research by Edelman, which came out in
December 2024, highlighted that only 32%
of US adults say they trust AI and only
44% of adults globally say they feel
comfortable with how businesses are
using AI. And the reason for that
unfortunately is AI slop. And as these
screen grabs show, uh AI slop is when
you go to use a website, a product, an
interface, and there's a geni genai
fail, uh where it gives you something
that you know is not correct. Whether
it's a search, a web search that tells
you you should eat rocks every day or a
website that tells you you can buy a car
for $1, we know that neither of those
things can be true.
website creators are stuffing AI
chatbots and everything and telling
users it's
magic but the real magic of Genai uh as
a Cassie Kosakov says you know it's it
is the fact that that it's a UX
revolution it's that users can actually
talk to a machine learning model in
natural language which has never been
possible before so with that in mind we
really want to think about the
capability of that and go back to some
UX first principles for us to figure out
how we want to use Genai to help
design. So going back to how it started,
you know, some writings by Don Norman of
the Neielson Norman group talk about the
design of everyday things, talking about
simplicity and efficiency. uh and he put
forward another great principle in his
book, The Invisible Computer, which
talks about invisible interfaces, which
is software that feels so seamless and
intuitive the users practically forget
that they're using it. And I think the
opportunity here is to use AI to design
interfaces that actually feel like
magic, not by stuffing chat bots into
the website, but by accelerating need
finding. And this part about need
finding is an asterisks because I just
want to make it clear I'm not a
designer. Uh you're not going to see
designs I produce today. I'm a data
scientist. But you are going to see a
proposal for a process for how we could
deliver this AI accelerated need
finding. So let's talk about what a new
approach to the design life cycle looks
like. Because in the world today, all of
us are bombarded with so many screens,
so much information, so much complexity.
It's a little bit akin to a pilot
operating in a cockpit. And the way that
pilots learn to s learn to operate in
this environment is actually through
simulation, through a lot of practice.
And I think we can take this idea of
simulation and evolve it and reinterpret
it a bit. Our current design process
which comes from the pre-CHAB GPT area
uh is data driven as designers collect
you know qualitative observations
uh quantitative data uh ethnog
ethnographic observations and they use
that to guide the prototyping
process. But going forward, what if we
could empower designers to work with
invisible users in the form of AI
simulation to turn the data artifacts
that they've always collected as part of
need finding to active participants in
the design process and give designers
their own mini feedback cycle to work
with AI simulation as part of the
broader need finding process to help
deliver better design.
So let's take an let's take a look at
what an example of an accelerated need
finding process could look like through
an example
project. So the new process for need
finding in the a era of AI simulation
has a lot of simil similarities with the
existing process. We're going to start
by defining our audience, then mapping
their intentions, identifying specific
tasks that will perform to accomplish
those intentions, conducting analysis of
that process, refining insights, and
ultimately developing design
alternatives. However, in this era of AI
simulation, there's going to be a few
key differences in some of the
components and some of the workflow.
So when we start thinking about
audiences in the area era of AI
simulation, we want to start with data
that represents these audiences. Uh and
at my company huge, we have a data
platform which we call live uh that has
a mixture of data sets demographic,
psychographic, contextual that allow us
to simulate audience behaviors in the
real world. And this is a critical
foundation to build on. Once we have
this foundation, the next step is to
actually apply intent mapping. And
here's where we turn the data into
something active, a simulation, which we
call an intelligent twin, which
represents a set of user behaviors and a
set of desired outcomes, their needs and
motivation. Intelligent twins become an
active participant in the design
simulation process.
And from there we can brief intelligent
twins to evaluate interfaces by focusing
on specific tasks much as we might brief
a human designer to conduct a heristic
analysis. And in this way we're able to
evaluate a specific interface or in the
case of this sample project a specific
website.
Now for the sample project I looked at
uh I wanted to think about the
advantages of this this simulated
methodology the scale and speed uh
intelligent twins can operate with
different levels of velocity than a
human team. So I wanted to apply that to
do a global uh audit of sports websites.
And we can imagine this happening from
the perspective of a business that
wanted to partner with sports leagues
globally and learn how to cut across
different countries, different cultures
uh to engage audiences there. And this
is where uh the intelligent twin
methodology could provide some unique
advantages. So in terms of the actual
data collection, so uh with intelligent
twins here in this sample project, I
actually broke them out into two
audiences, two personas. A casual fan
newer to sport versus super fan who's
lifelong and very savvy. And across
these three different websites, uh we
briefed a series of of tasks across
different categories like navigation,
information architecture, and fan
engagement. uh with four tasks per
category and that allows us to simulate
72 AI simulated actions uh to give uh to
give us a test drive for for how this AI
accelerated design audit will
perform when we get into the actual
findings. So uh with the speed and the
scale of intelligent twins, we can roll
these insights up at a very high level
or dive more granular as we'll see in
the next couple of slides. But one of
the benefits of this kind of global
audited speed is it gives us highlevel
understandings across an entire
category. And we can see from from this
audit that uh in the area of navigation
just kind of the starting place of a fan
coming to the website all the different
leagues we looked at um you know
basketball Olympics and the English
Premier League. All those sites
performed pretty well uh in terms of
task completion when it comes to
navigation. But as we get deeper into
the process, as fans started to browse
content and information architecture and
engagement pathways, that's where those
initial successes started to drop off.
And this goes back to the challenge I
mentioned at the start of the
presentation. Uh there's an AI trust gap
right now because AI is being shoved in
people's face and websites and it
doesn't work very well. But hopefully
this methodology could help us
understand what user pain points are and
actually solve those pain points and in
that way start to repair that trust
gap. We can also go deeper with this
methodology so we can scale the
simulation uh to surface friction across
specific areas, specific nuances of the
experience. uh the the the different
levels of altitude this methodology can
operate at allows us to create uh design
briefs which are really focused which
are really broad and really deep as well
and that's what we set up on this slide
here sort of closing out the audit
process uh through AI acceleration uh
computer use models computer vision
models uh human in the loop observation
we can use this process to generate a
design brief that allows the human team
to really focus in the pain points uh
that are that are distracting users in a
specific category and try to solve them.
And in that way uh we can use AI
simulation to to hopefully accelerate
and improve the design
process. As we look to the future in the
first half of 2025, there's been uh you
know tremendous progress. the the MCP
protocol from Anthropic is already
showing potential integrations to turn
prototype components in Figma through to
actual code components in React or
Node.js or other frameworks. Uh and this
is going to make it easier than ever to
create new designs. And I think as the
acceleration of these tools um just
makes it easier to create design that
really emphasizes the importance of
focusing on the why, the strategy and
the problem we want to solve for users
in the design process because it'll be
easier than ever to solve for the
how. In terms of this methodology,
obviously this is experimental early
stages. So there's some limitations and
improvements to consider going forward.
I think uh reproducibility is key. So as
we evolve this methodology, my company
and I will be standardizing things in a
code repository that lays out parameters
like the briefing instructions, the
simulated audience dimensions, the
number of audit runs and the parameters
from task completion and failure. And
also uh once we standardize this
applying it through a test and control
methodology will also be useful to help
us isolate what the strengths are of
intelligent twins for design need
finding and how that can be used
alongside or in a complimentary manner
to human teams especially applying to
different industries different
geographies and different domains.
In conclusion, just a few final thoughts
here. Uh, when it comes to repairing the
AI trust gap that we're struggling with
at the moment, uh, I hope we can all
recognize that users don't need more
websites that have Genai chat bots in
them that don't work. Uh, but users
could always benefit from from better
websites, better mobile apps, better
better surfaces that provide clarity and
simplicity. And hopefully uh I've been
able to show in this talk today how AI
simulation can be a tool to help us
empower design teams to gather insights
in a smarter, faster, and better process
and ultimately create websites and
interfaces that can restore and repair
the trust gap. Thank you.